hallo ich bin sarah ich gebe euch heute
einen kurzen überblick über die
deutschen fälle
hier seht ihr eine tabelle die tabelle
solltet ihr unbedingt auswendig lernen
damit ist es aber noch nicht getan um
die tabelle anzuwenden müsst ihr
unbedingt viel üben und das wollen wir
heute mit euch machen
wir fangen mit dem ersten und
einfachsten fall an
denn domina tief der domina tief fragt
wer oder was ist das zum beispiel das
ist der mann das ist die frau das ist
das kind das ist das fahrrad das ist der
baum das ist die tür
wir machen weiter mit dem genitiv der
genitiv kommt in der gesprochenen
sprache kaum noch vor
nach dem genitiv fragt man wissen zum
beispiel was ist das das ist die säule
dessen schatten ist dass das ist der
schatten der säule
was ist das das ist der totenkopf dessen
augen sind dass das sind die augen des
totenkopfes was ist das das ist das auto
dessen spiegel ist dass das ist der
spiegel des autos die häufigsten
deutschen fälle sind der dativ und
akkusativ nach dem dativ fragt man wem
gebe ich etwas nachdem akkusativ fragt
man wen sehe ich im dativ verändert sich
maskulinum zu dem termin um zu der und
neutrum auch zu dem hier habe ich eine
brille
ich gebe die brille
der frau wem gebe ich die brille der
frau
was ist das das ist der mann
ich gebe dem man die karte wem gebe ich
die karte dem man was ist das das ist
das kind das janisch mit photoshop hier
rein geklebt hat wem gebe ich keine
süßigkeiten
ich gebe dem kind keine süßigkeiten im
akkusativ ändert sich nur das maskulinum
es wird von dr
zu den zum beispiel was ist das das ist
der tisch was sehe ich
ich sehe den tisch was ist das das ist
der stuhl was sehe ich
ich sehe den stuhl im akkusativ
verändert sich das feminine um nicht zum
beispiel was ist das das ist die mütze
was sehe ich ich sehe die mütze
was ist das das ist das fahrrad was sehe
ich
ich sehe das fahrrad was ist das das ist
die schaufensterpuppe was sehe ich
ich wäre die schaufensterpuppe was ist
das das ist das auto was sehe ich
ich sehe das auto
das war es schon für heute mit der neuen
super easy german folge
ich hoffe ihr habt gemerkt dass es gar
nicht so schwierig ist
ihr müsst nur die tabelle
auswendiglernen und ganz viel üben
und genau das möchte ich jetzt immer
wieder mit euch machen und das war es
auch schon jetzt verabschiede ich mich
und vergess ich auf diesen t shirt
werdet ihr einen patch auf diesen t
shirt könnt ihr uns abonnieren und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]